(suspenseful music)
- [Narrator] People in Gaza are
being forced to use seawater
to clean themselves, wash their clothes,
and clean the dishes.
This is a result of Israel's siege,
which restricted the supply
of water, food, fuel, and medicine
into the Palestinian enclave
in response to Hamas's
deadly attacks on October 7.
(refugees speaking foreign language)
- [Narrator] The World
Health Organization said
that more than 2 million Gazans
have to get by on just three
liters of water per day
for drinking, cooking, and washing.
That's just 1/5 of the absolute minimum
of 15 liters needed for basic
survival according to the WHO.
(pump buzzing)
Gaza's water crisis began well
before the current conflict
between Israel and Hamas.
Most of Gaza's fresh water
comes from a shallow aquifer,
which was contaminated
with sewage and seawater
even before the war.
The UN has said that as much as 96% of it
is not fit for human consumption,
so Gazans had to rely on
unregulated private water tankers
and desalination plants
for drinking water.
There are three major desalination plants,
while some of the water
is purchased from Israel.
Years of conflicts worsened
the already inadequate
water infrastructure.
In 2007, Israel and Egypt
imposed a blockade on Gaza
after Hamas took over power in the strip.
That severely restricted
the entry of materials
to repair and maintain water systems.
Then, Israel ordered a total siege of Gaza
after the Hamas attacks.
(Yoav speaking foreign language)
- [Narrator] In the
aftermath of the assault,
Israel also turned off water pipelines.
In late October, Israeli officials said
that water was flowing through
two of the three pipelines.
As fuel started to run out,
two of the three
desalination plants in Gaza
had to shut down.
The last desalination plant
that's still in operation
was only working at 5%
capacity in late October.
All wastewater plants in Gaza
are shut down due to the lack of power,
resulting in raw sewage
flooding the streets.
(baby crying)
Since mid-October, more than 30,000 cases
of diarrhea have been
reported according to the WHO.
Over half of those are among
children under five years old.
The UN's Children's Agency
warns that in conflicts areas,
children under five are
20 times more likely
to die of diseases linked to
diarrhea than to violence.
(Rafif speaking foreign language)
- [Narrator] Long cues of people
waiting to fill Jerry cans
are now commonplace across the territory
as water becomes increasingly scarce.
The amount of water on
which Gazans rely on now
is a fraction of the WHO recommended range
of 50 to 100 liters a day.
And it's negligible compared
to what people in Israel consume
on average every day
according to a UN report.
(Magda speaking foreign language)
- [Narrator] The Israeli
military said Gaza
has sufficient water supplies,
as well as access to
solar power and diesel.
It accused Hamas of
limiting civilians' access
to those vital resources.
Hamas denies this.
What Gaza really needs according
to humanitarian organizations
is fuel to restore power.
Since the conflicts began on October 7,
Israel allowed only half a tanker of fuel
to enter the besieged enclave
via the Rafah border crossing with Egypt.
- Fuel here in Gaza is absolutely.
Everything was without fuel,
we do not have generator,
we do not have functioning bakery,
we do not have a functioning hospital,
and you cannot pump water.
- [Narrator] In mid-November,
the UN said 200,000 Gazans
lost access to clean water
after its two water distribution
contractors stop working
due to the lack of fuel.
(truck horn beeping)
Some aid trucks have entered
Gaza in recent weeks,
but the UN says
they are not bringing in
nearly enough fresh water.
(suspenseful music)